一切の生命の善友はいるんですよ
ママニアなんだ タイラーニミッターンアーダンジャージダニワッサータージャーキヤパリモッチャン
善友たる私 私ではない
釈迦像 あの善友たる私のところに来て
生まれる性質の修行は
生の輪廻から解放される
老いる 病に陥る 死す 修行は生老病死から解放される
だからお釈迦様が善友なんです
お釈迦様のところに来たら
お釈迦様の友達たちは生老病死
あらゆる煩悩で苦しんでいる
みんな転生で苦しんでいるんです
お釈迦様を友達にしてみれば
その苦しみから解放されて
解脱されて解脱に達するんです
ですから お釈迦様は断言して言うんですよ
あの善友っていうのはね
あれは私のことであると
あの隣の家の田中さんのことじゃないんだ
善友っていうのは釈迦牟尼仏のことなんです
憂い 悲しみ 悩み 苦しみに陥る修行は
それからそれらから解放される
だから人を成長させるはさせるわ
どんな苦しみからも人々を解放してあげます
お釈迦様は だからお釈迦様が唯一の絶対的な善友なんです
はい 最上の善友 修行を生老病死
憂い 悲しみ 悩み 苦しみという一切の苦しみから解放して
解脱に導くことが釈尊にできるのです
そのために真理を明かして八正道を語るのです
実践する人は皆 悟りに達する用に完全無欠の道を語るのです
人には親友がいなくても善友がいるのです
これが大事なポイントなんです
私の前の話の前のところを見ると
あ 善友ってのはありえないという感じになるでしょう
しかし 善友が一人いるのです
どんな人間でもお釈迦様なんです
友達がいなくても大丈夫ですよ
仲間がいなくても大丈夫です
それはただの仲間だからね
善友が必要です 善友が欠かせないんです
しかし どんな人にも善友がいるのです
お釈迦様こそが人類の生命の善友なのです
次の問題は ブッダは本当に友達になるんですかね
私の善友は釈尊ですという人は
ブッダを誤読しているのではありません
例えば あなたの友達は誰？あ
友達は釈迦様 大変笑っちゃう
笑われちゃうでしょ あんたね
そんな無力なこと言うなよ
でも大丈夫です 人間の友達はお釈迦様なんです
宗教は絶対的神に無条件に従う主人と奴隷の関係
一方的な関係を語るんです
宗教っていうのは 神という恐ろしいものがいて
人間という奴隷がいて
この恐ろしい神が言うとおりにしなくちゃいけないんです
でないと あまりにも怖い神だから
みんな永遠の地獄に落とす
それが宗教があたっての一方的な関係なんです
宗教を信仰する人の修行はいかに奴隷として服従するのかなんです
一切宗教はそこで集約できますからね
皆様も一人一人弁別してください
キリスト教やらイスラム教やらいろんな宗教がありますよ
この各宗教で完璧な信者さんって何なの？完璧な信者さんになるためには
いかに奴隷として神に服従するのかという
いわゆるサブミッショントゥゴッドなんです
解脱を語る仏教は無宗教なんです
無宗教です だから大丈夫です
仏教はサブミッションがいいまで服従ではなくて
解脱なんです 正反対なんです
世界の宗教と仏教はまるっきり違います
はい それからブッダは人を心配する
ヤンコチュンガサッターランカラミーヤンサーカーナンヒテーシナアヌカンパケーナアヌカンパンウパーダヤカタンウォータンマヤ
チュンガよ 弟子たちをいつくしも心配する師匠としてなすべきことを私はあなた方に対して成し終えた
お釈迦様はよく知っては自分が専有である
お釈迦様心配するんですよ
私は全部やってあげた
チュンガよ ここに切りであります
空き地があります 実践しなさい
怠る中で 後で後悔することにならないように
これがあなたたちに対する私のアドバイスです
度々見える言葉です いろんなところで
今日はちょこちょこで調べたところで
もう大体箇所ぐらい見つけたんですけどもね
いろんなところでこの文章が
これはマッジムニ会から取った文章ですけどね
チュンガというお坊さんに言うんです
説法してあげて チュンガに専有とおって
師匠とおって 私はできることは全部やっちゃった
ほら こちら木があるでしょ
空き地あるでしょ 修行したんです
後で後悔しないで 弟子は師匠を信頼する
いいエピソードがあります
これよく覚えてください
ウダナパーリの 3 番目のヤソージャスッタというところなんです
ヤソージャ比丘が 500人の比丘たちとともに釈尊に礼拝するために来ました
エピソードにも時間ないんだからね
あのヤソージャというお坊様が 500人の弟子たちを出家して
みんな新米なんです それでお釈迦様に会いましょう
祇園精舎に行ったんです
行ったらこの 500人でしょ
遠くから来たんだけど
みんな自分たちの住むところ
もう座るところとか酔いつぶるんですね
あの祇園精舎のお坊さんたちの喋ってれば
このお坊さんが名前何ですか？とかね
出家して何年ですか？とかね
500人が喋るとものすごいうるさくなるんですね
それでお釈迦様はアーナンダ尊者じゃない
アーナンダ 結構うるさいんだけど
何者かと言ったら お釈迦様
このヤソージャさんが 500人の新米の比丘たちと一緒に来ています
あ そう 呼びなさいと言ったら
それを呼んだんです 呼んだらお釈迦様どなったんですね
あんた方はね 魚売場のように何たることですか
こちら こんなにうるさくて
魚売ってるわけじゃないですよね
こっちは 出て行け 追い出された
出て行くと言ったら このヤソージャお坊様が 500人のお坊さんたちと一緒にお釈迦様のところを 3回回って礼拝をして出て行くんです
立ちまち出て行くわけですね
それでヤソージャを比丘比丘がわっじ国に入ってワックムリ
という川辺で 川岸で枯れ葉でいおりを作って
おわんこに入ったんです
かなり遠く遠く お釈迦様といるところとかなり離れたんです
弟子たちにこのように語る
バガターマイハウスを棚にいった
あったかめに否定した
アヌカンパケのアヌカンパムパー
この夜想お坊さんが師匠なんです
弟子先に言うんですよ
あの 君たち知ってましたね
お釈迦様 我々を水平しまった
で それをお釈迦様が我々のことを心配するんだ
我々の幸福を願ってますよ
このアヌカンパは否定しないっていうのはあまり日本語できません
この我々に対して偉大なる憐れみを持ってます
そういう人が我々を水平しまった
我々の成長を期待する
心配する憐れみ 釈尊に水平水平だから
釈尊に喜ばれるように
我らは生活 修行修行ではありませんよ
リンパでしょ 怒ってないです
お釈迦様は母親より慈しみがあるんだから
出て行けと言ったら何か意味がある
だからお釈迦様に褒めてもらうように
これから修行を頑張ろうではないかと思って頑張っちゃったんです
たちまちみんな人相力とともに悟り出したのです
そこで お釈迦様が このビョン村から出てワッチ国に入ったんです
ワッチ国に入ったら アナンダ尊者にこう言うんです
あのワック無断という川のところは
なんか私にとって非常に気になるんだと
気に入るんだ なんかそこら辺からすごい楽しい波動が来るんだ
だからアーナンダ あの
あの比丘たちにぜひ来てくださいと
誰か送ってください 連絡してください
いうと アナンダ尊者が連絡を送ったんです
送ったらこの お坊さんがね
お釈迦様が呼ばれているんだよと言われた瞬間で
たちまち人相でそこに来ちゃって
お釈迦様のところに 501人現れるんです
だからお釈迦様に怒られてもありがたく思うんです
あ よかった 何かそれで我々は導かれます
次に専有が必要かってこと
心は貧弱で揺れ動くもので
守りがたい アンダナンチャパランチッタンブラ環境には対象に依存してのみ機能するのです
心は常にマインドコントロールされています
心は必ず周りの影響を受ける
人格を完成して幸福に達する
解脱を経験する気持ちがあるならば
優れた環境の中に自分を置いておくことです
だから心っていうのは優柔不断で揺れ動くんですよ
対象がないと心は機能しないんです
だからその心を強化して悟りに達したければ
素晴らしい環境に入れるしかないんです
だから人間に専有がいるんです
必要です 欠かせないです
はい また経典に戻ります
こうした国王に続けてお釈迦様が語るんです
あの一つの経典の紹介ですけど
間にいくつかの証券を差し込みましたからね
大王よ 専有がいる人は一つのことを守るべきです
では 皆様にはもう友人は分かりませんだけど
専有が一人います 確実にお釈迦様がいるんです
では お釈迦様という偉大なる専有がいるんだから
師匠がいるんだから 親がいるんだから
お釈迦様が言うんです
条件一つあります それは良いことに対して不放逸であることなんです
あったまあるくせです
ダメです 放逸はダメですよ
従順に頑張ってください
だから我々も 私も皆様もお釈迦様がおっしゃったことは怠けずやろうではないかという気分があれば
お釈迦様は守ってくれます
導いてくれます 王が怠らないとき
後ろを後ろにいる皆が怠らなくなる
それから従事する王家の親族たちも不放逸になる
それから軍人も不放逸に励む
それに従って伴って国民も不放逸で励む
自分が不放逸になることで自分も守られる
お妃たちも守られる 国交も守られると
これ王様に俗世間の話をするんです
あなた王様 あなた不放逸になりなさい
あなたに私が専属がいるでしょ
あなた不放逸で頑張ると
お城の人々も大臣たちもみんな頑張ります
そうすると軍人も頑張ります
そうすると国民も頑張ります
それで国絶対守ったことになります
国交を守ったことになります
そういうことはないんだから
日本の国は大変でしょ
もうだからやっぱり放逸の方がよろしい
はい まとめの言葉 はい
パーリ語を読みましょう
飛ばしましょう ボーゲパッテーマーネーネウラーレヤパラータレアッパマーダンパサンサンティプンニャッキリアスパンディタ
この世でもあの世でも偉大なる富
幸福を期待する理性のある人
善行為において不放逸を称賛する
いわゆるこの世であの世で幸福になりたければ
不放逸を実践してくださいっていう意味なんです
アッパマッタオゴワッテアリガッアディガンナーティパンディトディッテワダンネヨーチャットヨーチャットサンパラエポアッタディサメオディドパンディトウティパウッチャティ
この世で達するべき意義
幸福 あの世で達するべき意義
幸福 不放逸の者が達する
有為義 幸福を目指す理性ある人の人こそ賢者というのですと
あの友人関係はお釈迦様が不放逸で終了するんです
友人がいれば 不放逸が備わっていればもう完璧である
善友がいて自分が頑張る
それだけなんです それで一切の幸福が得られますよ
解脱だけじゃない この世の幸福
あの世の幸福 ありとあらゆる幸福に達しますということで
試しを終了します どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]